for all these people are hustling out
there who are like I don't know when my
breakthrough is going to happen I don't
know when it's gonna happen either and I
think a lot of it just takes a change of
mindset to just saying like I just need
to get better I think that a lot of it
has to come down to like how you're
measuring time and then how you see the
effort that you're putting in and so if
you get good enough that breakthrough
happens eventually it's more real to me
now than it was when I made that video
it's about measuring in decades not days
and I don't say that as a patient's
platitude but I say that we have to
think about things that we'd be willing
to do for a very long period of time so
if you're not really willing to do the
thing that you're doing right now for a
very long period of time it probably
means that whatever it is doesn't
motivate you because it's not meaningful
to you if you don't think of the
long-term thing as like a patient's
Mantra but more so a I need alignment to
what I really want to do Mantra that's
what will give you the stick-to-it-ness
to be able to go through the harder
times because nothing big happens
overnight it just takes time